entre besançon et la malate la
circulation reprend avec les beaux jours
joggeurs cyclistes kayakistes sont de
plus en plus nombreux or il y avait là
un danger invisible des arbres malades
qui menaçait de tomber et que les
bussereau a bat 1200 freine le long de
l'ancien chemin de halage après les 3000
récemment coupé dans la forêt de
chailluz et nous n'oublions pas qu'il
faut qu'on voit si on peut améliorer la
situation du frêne ou au mieux on a très
peu d'espoir mais on va laisser le plus
possible de chance à une régénération au
sein des parcelles mais on est obligés
aujourd'hui de sécuriser les routes les
sentiers les plaisons de pique nique les
aires de parking etc etc venues de l'est
est apparue il ya dix ans en france la
callas rose décime les frênes après un
été trop sec en 2018 il a fallu se
rendre à l'évidence et procéder à de
l'abattage massif
contre lac à la rose pas de remède le
frêne pourri de l'intérieur s'affaiblit
et meurt c'est un champignon pathogène
qui s'en prend à la fois aux rameaux
branche l'extrémité des branches donc on
voit des dessèchement de branches à 2
sur les extrémités principalement et
puis après il ya des atteintes dans un
second temps au pied de l'arbre
donc là enfin l'arbre est vraiment
fragilisé au pied ces abattages vont
conduire à de nouveaux éclaircissements
dans les forêts et réduire la
biodiversité
ces dernières années en plus du frêne
l'épicéa et surtout l'orme ont été
dessinés par des maladies